so what's your news Kira Kira all right
so we have a sister Kirra over here and
at hamdullah she took her Shahada she
embraced Islam and her mom is also here
who is supporting her right but I'm just
so curious masha'Allah such a young
sweet girl she embraced Islam what made
her to study Islam and now al
hamdulillah to embrace Islam to Sakura
good job I just did research in I kindly
walked away from it and I just kept me
on the back burner in my mind and I just
did me search occasionally from there
and then I have my friend she's done I
decided to really get into it and really
learn more about it and so that's how I
came to how do you feel when you are
wearing the hijab do you feel different
how do you feel okay I do I do feel
different
I don't feel pressured from society be
like wearing makeup wearing like a few
hairstyle like I don't feel any of those
societal pressures anymore and I feel
like I can really be me and myself
without worrying how I look on the
outside wonderful you know you have your
mom over here mom what's your name Sarah
Sarah how do you feel your daughter
right she made it a really important
decision in her life how do you feel
about her becoming a Muslim she didn't
so we've always encouraged our children
to follow down paths whatever that was I
mean carotenes me and told me she was
researching Islam and so we support her
in that
red grunts and said that it spoke to her
and she's had positive improvements to
her overall itself and so yeah we're at
the beginning of the journey but it's
making some flora and I'm supporting her
and however I can do that
have you also read the Quran bother me I
know your daughter perhaps you did what
about you I have meaning to read in
English so yeah working on it looks like
you have a gift back and you want to
show that gift back what do you have for
the other side yes I got some really
good information I actually have wow
that's a translation that's really good
questions know the 50 common questions
people ask yes reading up in supporting
care how I can hear what one message
that you have to other youth other kids
who may also be searching for the truth
they may have so much societal pressure
what message that you have for them I
just say to yourself and it's okay to
question things like if you're from a
different religion you know like I don't
think this is for me it's okay to
question it like it's okay too much for
the truth because it's out there what in
Islam that you like the most by the way
there's so many wonderful things in
Islam right yes I'd say definitely the
women's rights has definitely changed
and I do not believe that Islam
oppresses women which is another thing
that likes I know in Christianity and
our religion that women were definitely
oppressed and that's why I really can
you mention one of the rights that Islam
gave to women that she said you know wow
there's a wonderful what right came to
your comes to your mind so I have a
cross right for one's own property which
at the time was like unthinkable and so
I thought that was a very
exactly yeah you know in Islam Islam
gave women the right to or property in
the seventh century in Illinois in USA
not until 1861 that a married lady she
won the right to a property in Islam
gave that right 1,400 years ago and many
many rights that Islam give to women
right they have the right to education
they know that the oldest continuous
university in the whole world it was
built by a Muslim lady it was built by a
Muslim girl actually just like you she
wrote the hijab and she made the oldest
continuous university this there's
amazing correct she has the right to
work if the need arises
whatever she earns it only belongs to
her they have the right not to be forced
into marriage so what one message that
you have for your mom
[Music]
researching as well because there's so
much more that even I don't know about
and there are so many wonderful things
in it that I want her to know as well
and I want Presbyterians and I just so
that she makes the right choices for
yourself
alright and you wish your mom to also
join you one day yes